The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: All
right, so last time we
started talking about
energy absorption,
and I wanted to try to
finish that up today.
And then next week we would
talk about sandwich panels
and using honeycombs and
foams in sandwich panels.
So I think we got
as far as the idea
of introducing what these
energy absorption diagrams are.
So let me run through this
little sequence again,
and then I'll put the
notes up on the board.
So the idea is that you have
your compressive stress strain
curve-- so here's a series of
curves for different densities
of a foam.
And we would do these
all at the same strain
rate and temperature, so
that those aren't variables.
And then what we would do is
we could turn those into energy
absorption diagrams.
So notice here,
this is a log plot.
So here's that energy
absorption here.
Here's the peak stress
here-- so that's
the peak stress up to some level
of energy that you've absorbed.
And we've normalized both of
those by the solid modulus.
So say we look at one density
here, say we look at the lowest
density-- 0.01.
So here's our curve
here for the test.
If I go up to some
stress level that's
still in the linear
elastic region,
then that's going to translate
into somewhere along here
on the energy absorption curve.
And one of the
things we're going
to do today-- I'm going to
show you how you draw these,
and how you can set them up.
And you can either get
them from experiments--
so this is, say the top curve
were experiments, doing it
from experiments-- or you can
use the models for the foams
to do it, as well.
So we'll see how you
can do from both ways.
So this would be the
linear elastic bit here.
This vertical part-- where
the energy is increasing,
but the peak stress isn't
increasing-- that corresponds
to the plateau here.
And then this part here,
where the energy is not
increasing very much,
but the stress increases
a lot-- that corresponds to the
densification part over there.
So what you would do
is you would do tests
on foams of different densities,
and from the test data,
you could draw an
energy absorption
curve for each density.
So you plot-- there's four
different densities here,
so it forms a family
of these curves.
And then what you
do is you say--
and I think we talked
with this last time--
that the place you want to
be is at this shoulder point.
You want to be absorbing
as much energy as possible
at that plateau stress.
So you want to be at the point
just before it turns around
to the densification regime.
So you can mark that
little shoulder point
for each density.
So here's like 0.01,
here's 0.03, and so on.
And then those points can
be connected by a line--
so that heavy line then
connects those shoulder points,
or those optimum points.
And then what you can do is
then repeat this whole process
for different strain rates.
So this family of lines here
is at different strain rates--
so this set that goes this way,
corresponds to this line here.
And if you do them at
different strain rates,
where the shoulder appears at
a slightly different point--
and so if you mark
those shorter points,
you can draw these lines
here that connect up
for one relative density.
So this line on the
left hand side here,
these are all relative
densities of 0.01,
these ones are all
relative densities of 0.03.
So this diagram down
here, doesn't really
look like this at
all-- it doesn't
look like the basic
energy absorption diagram.
But it actually has
information for what
the optimum would be
for a range of densities
and a range of strain rates.
So typically, these
foams are viscoelastic
and they have some
strain rate sensitivity.
So you'd like to get the strain
rate sensitivity into it.
And it's not shown
here, but you could
do the same thing at
a constant strain rate
and varying the
temperature, too.
So if you had things at
different temperatures,
you could do the
same kind of idea.
OK-- so are we good
with how this works?
Because now I'm going to
write some notes on the board
so you have it in your notes.
So the idea is that you turn
your stress strain curve
to look something like that,
into an energy absorption
diagram.
And you can plot on log
log scales, the energy
versus the peak stress.
And you get something like that.
And this point here, I'm going
to call the shoulder point.
And that would use the material
in the most efficient way--
you get the most energy
absorption without getting
higher than that plateau stress.
So we can say at this stress
plateau, the energy increases
without much increase
in the peak stress.
And then as the foam
densifies, then you
get an increase in
that peak stress,
with little increase
in the energy absorbed.
And so ideally, you want to
be at that shoulder point.
So to construct these
energy diagrams,
you can test the series of foams
at different relative densities
and constant strain
rate and temperature.
And then you make that
plot of the energy absorbed
normalized by the solid
modulus, versus the peak stress
modulus for each curve.
And typically what people
do is they would take
the solid modulus at a constant
strain rate and temperature,
so you don't have to
introduce that, as well.
Then you would mark the density
for each of those shoulder
points, and then you
would connect them.
And then you could
repeat this whole process
for different strain rates.
And then you would
draw the final diagram
at the bottom, where you have
this family of lines that
describes the shoulder points
for different densities
and different strain rates.
And you could treat different
temperatures in the same way,
if you wanted to.
You would hold the
strain rate constant,
and vary the temperature.
so it's kind of a nice
way of just putting
a lot of information
in one diagram.
So one of the
things about this is
that, because we're
normalizing by Es,
and if you think of elastomeric
foams, elastomeric foams,
both the Young's
modulus depends on Es,
and the plateau
stress depends Es.
So the Young's modulus depends
on the stiffness of the solid,
and also because
the plateau stress
is related to elastic
buckling, it also
depends on the
modulus of the solid.
So for elastomeric foams--
it's because you normalized it
with respect to Es--
one of these diagrams
will represent all
elastomeric foams.
So that's rather a
nice thing-- so you
can have different
elastomeric foams,
but one of those diagrams is
going to represent all of them.
So we can say,
elastomeric foams can all
be plotted on one
plot, or one curve,
since both the modulus
and the plateau stress
are related to Es.
So if we look at this
next figure here--
maybe I'll just wait a minute
for people to stop writing.
Some people write
faster than others.
So if we look at
this next plot here,
here's a compressive
stress and strain.
These tests are done
for one density,
but at different strain
rates-- so it's kind
of the other version of this.
But here's the stress
strain curves here,
and here's the energy
absorption diagram that's
derived from those.
And then here's
a summary diagram
that has the different
strain rates, and that would
have different densities here.
And the idea is
this diagram here
could represent all
elastomeric foams.
So this has been put
together for polyurethane,
but it should be able
to represent other sorts
of flexible elastomeric foams.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: In those
diagrams, then,
the intersection
of this strain rate
line and your
relative density line
should be the shoulder position?
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, exactly.
And so this line here is for
0.01, and that one's for 0.03.
So 0.02 is going
to be-- you'd have
to interpolate somewhere
in between there.
So we've just put
on certain values,
because we're not going to
put on a million values.
We just put on certain
ones, and then you
can estimate where
other densities would
appear on there.
OK?
So here's another
example here-- these are
curves for two different foams.
So here's a polyurethane
a polyethylene,
so these are both elastomers.
And one is the dashed line,
and one is the solid line.
And you can kind of see
how the lines mesh up.
So here's a density of
0.01 for the polyurethane.
Here's 0.05 for
the polyurethane.
And here's 0.06 for
the polyethylene.
And you can see how
the 0.06 and 0.05--
they're not quite on
top of each other,
but they're pretty close to
coming on top of each other.
And then 0.1, 0.12-- and
so you get a family of them
for the different densities.
And you can also do
this for materials
that have a yield point, so
polymethacrylimid has a yield
point, so you do exactly
the same kind of thing.
So here's the energy
absorption diagram
that's been developed from
the stress strain curves.
But now this curve here,
or this set of curves here,
is really just valid for
one ratio of sigma [? ys ?]
to Es-- so the solid yield
strength of the solid modulus.
So it's valid for
whatever it was
for that particular type of
foam-- the polymethacrylimid.
So I'll just say,
if we have foams
that are made from a
material with a yield point--
and so they have a plastic
collapse stress-- then
the curve will be
valid for foams
with the same ratio of
[? sigma ys ?] to Es.
So in that case there,
for the polymethacrylimid,
that ratio is about
equal to 1 over 30.
So that plot would probably
give not a bad description
of other foams, with the same
value of sigma ys over Es.
So the idea here
is we can generate
these diagrams either
from data-- the way
those ones have been
done-- or from the models.
So another way to generate these
is to think about the models
that we have for the foams,
and the foam behavior.
So we have an equation that
describes the Young's modulus,
we have equations that
describe the plateau stresses,
we have an empirical equation
for the densification strain.
And we can use those to
generate these diagrams.
And they're kind of
useful, because they
show you what's going on a
sort of mechanistic basis.
So this is a diagram here that's
been generated for open cell
elastomeric foams.
Here's our energy
absorbed, here's
our peak stress down here.
This little inset is sort of a
schematic of the idealized foam
behavior.
So here's the Young's
modulus, here's
the elastic [? collapse ?]
stress, here's
the densification over here.
So obviously it's kind of
a very idealized set-up.
But we can generate
this diagram--
and I'm going to go
through the equations that
will let us do that.
So one thing to note is here's
the curves for each density.
Here is this line that
connects the shoulder points.
There's a couple of
other lines on here
that I just wanted to
mention something about.
If you think about the
densities-- like that's 0.01,
this is 0.03,
that's 0.1-- if you
had a fully dense solid that
was made of the same elastomer,
you could plot the
curve for that,
and that is going to
show up over here.
So this is kind
of an upper bound.
It can't get any more from that.
And we've also got
a dotted line here,
which takes into account
fluid flow within the cells.
So there can be some
fluid flow, and because we
haven't talked about that,
we're not going to go into that.
So we can just ignore
that dotted line for now.
So let me go through how
we can do the modeling.
So we're going to divide
the stress strain curve up
into bits, and I'm
going to write equations
for the energy
absorbed for each bit.
So we're going to start with
a linear elastic behavior.
And I'm going to--
let's see-- yeah,
so let me just note here that
this is the densification
strain out here.
And this strain, epsilon
naught, corresponds
to the strain at which we
first reach the stress plateau.
So here, for the
linear elastic part,
I'm going to say that the
strain is less than that.
So the strain is less
than absolute naught.
And then I can say,
the energy absorbed--
so if you just
remember from Hooke's
law on linear elasticity,
energy under the stress strain
curve for the
linear elastic part
is 1/2 of sigma
squared over E. So I'm
going to call sigma-- whatever
the stress is going to be,
the peak stress that we get to.
And now we're going to
divide by E of the foam--
because these were
our foams here.
And I can use our
model here to say--
and now I've got to
divide that by Es,
because I've normalized here.
So because I know
from my modeling
that the Young's
modulus of the foam
is just equal to Es times
the relative density squared
for the open celled
foam, that means
I've now got an Es squared
in the denominator,
so I've got a sigma
p over Es squared.
And then I've got a 1 over the
relative density squared term.
So that factor there,
that equation there,
gives you these first
set of lines here.
Gives you that bit, and
this bit, and that bit.
So it gives you those first
parts of the energy absorption
diagram.
And then if we look at
the stress plateau--
so here we're going to say
that epsilon naught is less
than epsilon is less than
the densification strain--
so we're on the
plateau somewhere.
And now the energy
absorbed is just
going to be our plateau stress
times the amount of strain
we've got.
So that's epsilon
minus epsilon naught.
And if I normalized with
respect the solid modulus,
I can write down that my
plateau stress is 0.05 times
the relative density
squared, and then
multiply that times epsilon
minus epsilon naught.
So that equation
then corresponds
to these vertical parts--
so this part here, that part
there, this part here.
It corresponds to those
vertical lines on the figure.
Vertical lines on the diagram.
And then the plateau
stress is going
to end at the
densification strain.
And at that point,
the energy diagram
is just going to
become vertical.
OK, and then the
last part-- I'll
try to rub this off
a little better.
And then the last
part is when we're
at the end of this
stress plateau,
and the strain is equal to
that densification strain.
And so the amount of
energy we absorb here
is really going
to be the maximum.
So this is the
energy that's going
to correspond to
that shoulder point
that I've been talking about.
So I'm going to call that W max,
and normalize that with respect
to Es.
And that's then going
to be our plateau stress
times the densification strain.
And the densification strain
was just 1 minus 1.4 times
the relative density.
So here I'm assuming that
the densification strain
is very much bigger
than the strain at which
the buckling first
occurs, and I'm neglecting
that linear elastic part.
So then we could say
that the optimum foam
is at that shoulder point.
And I can say that the
peak stress at that point
is just equal to
the plateau stress.
And what I want to do is get
an equation for that solid line
up here that connects all
those shoulder points.
So I want an equation,
in terms of the energy,
and the peak stress, instead
of in terms of the density.
So what I'm going to do a
solve this for the density,
and then plug that
back into there.
So I get that the
relative density is, then,
20 times the peak stress
over the solid modulus,
and I take the
square root of that.
And now I can substitute this up
here for the relative density.
I think I need another board.
So then I've got-- this is
my peak stress, or my plateau
stress, over Es, and this is all
just the densification strain.
And that's just 1 minus 1.4
times the relative density.
But now I'm putting
the relative density
in terms of the peak stress,
or the plateau stress.
If I just simplify that
slightly with the constant,
it's 1 minus 6.26 times sigma
p over Es to the 1/2 power.
So that equation there describes
the-- oops, no more updates.
No updates.
Go away.
Ah, so that equation there
describes this line here that
connects those shoulder points.
And that's the line you're
the most interested in,
because each of
those shoulder points
is a point where
the foam is being
used in the most efficient
way, or the optimum way.
And then, let's see--
is that going to fit?
No-- let me try the other board.
And then the last
thing we can do
is calculate that line that
corresponds to the dense solid.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: On those
ones over there,
it says it corresponds to the
vertical lines on the diagram.
And then later it says
then it becomes vertical.
Is that referring to
two different diagrams?
LORNA GIBSON: So this
stress plateau equation
here corresponds to these
vertical lines here.
So for relative density of 0.01,
it corresponds to that part.
For 0.03 it's this part.
And your 0.01 it's that part.
AUDIENCE: But then
some of the [INAUDIBLE]
it says, then w [? versus ?]
sigma becomes vertical.
Should that--
LORNA GIBSON: So, well
the plateau stress
ends at the
densification strain.
So the plateau stress ends here.
Oh, let's see-- and then it
becomes-- should be horizontal.
Sorry.
OK, sorry.
Happy?
And now I'm going
to rub that all off.
OK, did everybody get this?
I can rub it off?
OK, so then the last
part is what happens
when the foam is densified.
And if it was fully dense--
and you never really
can get to this point--
but if it was fully dense,
you would get rid
of all the pores,
and it would just be a solid.
And then the energy
absorption curve
would be the curve
for the solid.
So I'll just say,
when fully densified,
I'm going to say a curve
approaches that for the solid.
And for the solid, you would
just have that W over Es
is equal to 1/2 the peak
stress squared over Es.
So this model curve, the
curves have the same shape
as when you get the diagrams
from the experiments.
And you can see how the
different mechanisms
of deformation and failure
contribute to the diagram,
where the diagram comes from.
And I guess one
other point is you
can see that the foams are
always going to be a lot better
than the solid.
And remember this
is a log log curve,
so that a foam that has a
density of 3% here, there's
a huge difference
in the peak stress.
So say you wanted to absorb
this amount of energy up here,
for a foam that was 0.03
dense, the peak stress
would be a little less
than 10 to the minus 4,
normalized by the modulus.
And for the solid, it would
be 10 to the minus 2--
so it's orders of
magnitude better to have
the foam rather than the solid.
All right, now let's
see what else we have.
So we could do a similar
thing for closed-cell foams,
and you get diagrams
that look like this.
One of the differences with
the closed-cell foams, if you
assume that the faces don't
rupture, the plateau stresses
and horizontals-- remember
we had that gas contribution,
and you can take
that into account?
So I'm not going to go
over the details of that.
The next one I
wanted to talk about
was looking at foams
that have a yield point.
And again, you can generate
a similar kind of diagram,
but now, instead of having
an elastic failure here,
you've got a plastic failure--
you form plastic hinges.
And then again,
this diagram is less
general than the one
for elastomeric foams,
so this diagram would be valid
for whatever ratio of sigma ys
over Es you've the
calculation for.
So this one here is for 0.01.
So let me just run through
the same kind of calculation
for the plastic foams.
Can I rub this
off, and then I can
use this board to start here?
OK, so the linear elastic
part is just the same
as for the elastomeric foams.
So you get W over Es is 1/2.
Sigma p over Es squared times
1 over the relative density
squared, so it's
just the same thing.
And the stress plateau--
you get w over Es
is just the plastic collapse
strength times the strain range
that you go up to.
So if you remember the
plastic collapse strength
was 0.3 sigma ys times the
relative density to the 3/2
power, and then times
the strain range.
And then at the end
of the stress plateau,
you've got the maximum
energy absorbed.
So normalize that by Es.
And that's going to be
your peak stress over Es
times the densification
strain again.
So this bit here is the
densification strain.
And then you can
do a similar thing
to figure out the
equation of that line that
joins the shoulder points.
So the first step is to solve
for the relative density there.
So if this part here-- 0.3 sigma
ys times the relative density
to the 3/2 power is the
plastic collapse stress,
then at the densification
point, the relative density,
you just rewrite that and it
comes out to the 2/3 power,
because you turn
the power around.
And then you just
substitute this up in here.
So you get that the
maximum energy absorbed,
normalized by the solid modulus,
is your peak stress, times
1 minus 1.4 times this thing
in brackets to the 2/3 power--
the 3.3 times the peak
stress over the yield
strength of the solid.
And then if I just rearrange
that, and get the constants,
it's 1 minus 3.1 times our
ratio of the stresses there.
So maybe I'll just
put over here--
the curves are less general
than for elastomeric foams.
So each family of
curves would be
for a particular ratio of
the solid yield strength
to the solid modulus.
So you get the idea?
It's fairly straightforward.
So I wanted to
finish up this topic
by giving you a few examples of
how you can use these curves.
So the next thing is to look
at the selection of foams
for impact protection.
And typically, you're given some
information about the objects--
so typically you want
to protect some object.
It could be a computer,
it could be your head,
some part of your body.
So typically you know
something about the object
you want to protect.
So you might know its mass, you
might know the area of contact,
you might say, well,
if it's my computer,
I want to make sure it
doesn't break if I drop it
from a height of a meter.
Or you could say whatever,
[? maybe it's ?] 2 meters.
But you pick something.
And so there's a
certain amount of energy
you know that you
need to absorb.
And you may know that
whatever the component is,
or the body part, or
whatever-- there's
some maximum acceleration
you can tolerate.
So you might say,
well, I want to make
sure my computer doesn't break
under acceleration of so much.
So you're given
the acceleration.
And so if you know the
mass and the acceleration,
and you know the
area of contact,
you can figure out a
force over an area,
and that gives you
the peak stress.
So typically, you know
those things in the problem.
And typically the problem
involves choosing a material,
or choosing-- like choosing
what kind of material
do you want to make the foam
out of, and what density of foam
do you want to use,
what thickness of foam
do you want to use?
So I've got a couple
of examples just
to show you how this works.
So let me just write down
a couple notes, and then
the rest of it I think I'm just
going to take from the slides.
So typically, you know what
it is you want to protect,
and you know something about it.
So if you know what
it is, typically you
know what the mass is.
You might know what the
contact area would be.
Say a maximum drop height,
maximum tolerable acceleration.
So say if you're worried
about brain injury--
and making a helmet-- you might
know what the maximum tolerable
acceleration would be.
So typically, you know what the
peak allowable stress is, just
from whatever the
object itself is.
And the variables that
you have to play around
with-- variables-- are things
like the foam material,
the foam density, and
the foam thickness.
So I have a couple
of examples that
have different setups here.
And we'll just see how
the thing works out here.
So the first example, we're told
the mass of the packaged object
is 1/2 kilogram.
We're told the area of
contact between the foam
and the object is
going to be point.
0.01 of 1 meter squared.
And we're told
that it's supposed
to be designed to withstand
a drop of 1 meter--
so if the drop
height is 1 meter,
then the velocity is just
the square root of 2gh.
So g is gravity, so you can
work out the velocity on impact
would be 4.5 meters per second.
And if you have the velocity
on impact and the mass,
you can figure out the
energy to be absorbed.
You can say mv squared
screwed over 2,
or you could say it's
mgh-- either way.
So here it's going to
work out to 5 joules.
And in this case, we're told
that the maximum deceleration
is 10g-- so then if that's 10g,
the maximum force is the mass
times the acceleration.
That works out to 50 Newtons.
And then that gives
us a peak stress,
the maximum
allowable peak stress
of the force over the area
it's 5 kiloNewtons per meter
squared.
And in this case, we're
told that the foam is
going to be a
flexible polyurethane,
and it has a solid
modulus of 50 megapascals.
And so we can calculate
this normalized peak stress.
So the normalized peak stress
here is 10 to the minus 4.
So in this problem here,
we need to figure out
what's the foam
density, and what's
the thickness of the foam
to protect the object?
And so that last slide
is just summarized here.
And I realized that when I
was going to put this up,
the font is going
to be kind of small,
so I blew it up a little.
So we have figured
out that we're
at sigma p over Es-- the
peak stress normalized
by the solid modulus
is 10 to the minus 4.
And we know that
we're going to use
a flexible elastomeric
polyurethane,
so we pull out our diagram
for elastomeric foams.
And this sort of
hashed band here
corresponds to all the
different strain rates, and all
the different densities.
So I haven't plotted
each individual line,
we've just got this band that
represents the whole thing.
So we know that
our normalized peak
stress is going to be
somewhere along this line here.
That's from everything
that's given,
and what we can calculate.
And we want to know what
density of foam to use,
and what thickness.
So the way you approach
this is the thickness
is going to affect
the strain rate.
So the strain rate's just going
to be the velocity on impact,
divided by the thickness--
or it's an approximation
for the strain rate.
So we don't know if we're
at this point down here,
or if we're at this
point up there,
because we don't know where
we are in the strain rate
end of things.
So the way you solve this is
you just guess a thickness.
And if you guess
a thickness, you
can calculate a strain rate.
Then if you calculate
the strain rate,
you know where in
this band you are.
You can figure out a
value of W over Es.
And you can use an
iterative process.
And the way this
is set up is we've
chosen two very different
initial thicknesses,
and the point of doing
that is to show you
that it converges very quickly.
So the first
iteration on this side
here, we've chosen the
thickness of a meter, which
is probably unlikely that
we need a meter of foam.
And on the side here, we've
chosen a millimeter-- 0.001
meters.
So probably, we
need more than that.
So we probably need
to be somewhere
between those two bounds.
So if the thickness was a
meter, then the strain rate
turns out to be 4.5 per second.
And then we know where
we are in this diagram,
and we can read off
a value of W over Es.
So we know we're
on this line here,
and for a particular
strain rate,
we can read off the W over Es.
So here's the value-- 5.25
times 10 to the minus 5.
And if we know Es,
which we do, we
can then calculate
the actual energy
absorbed per unit volume.
We get W-- so W is [? 2620 ?]
joules per cubic meter.
And we can use that
value-- because that's
an energy per unit volume--
we know the area of contact,
and we can use that to get
another value of the thickness.
So we use that to calculate
the next iteration
of the thickness.
So U is the total
energy in joules,
and W is the energy
per unit volume.
So U, the energy
in joules, is going
to equal the energy unit
volume times the area
times the thickness.
So we know what
the area is, too.
We can then calculate
a new thickness.
So now our new thickness
is 0.19 meters.
We can use that to
get a new strain
rate-- that's 24 per second,
and go through the whole thing
again.
And we end up with a revised
energy of 3,300 joules
per cubic meter.
Now if we started
at the other end,
if we started with the first
guess was a millimeter, then
the strain rate is 4.5 times
10 to the minus 3 per second.
That gives us a different
value that we read off here
for W over Es, and a
different value for W.
And then we use this
value here for W
to make another guess
for the thickness.
So that value is 0.14.
And then we go through
the whole thing
again-- we get a revised strain
rate a revised W over Es,
and a revised W. And you can
see after just two iterations,
these two things are
almost exactly the same.
And then on the
third iteration, they
both would give you a
thickness of point 0.15 meters.
So even though you can pick
wildly wrong first iterations,
it converges very quickly,
and it's a fairly simple
calculation to do.
So you know the thickness
that you want is in here,
and then you can get the
optimum density here.
So you know that your sigma
p over Es is along this line
of 10 to the minus
4--we're somewhere in here.
These two strain rates
here-- one was 24,
one was 32-- so the
final value is going
to be somewhere around 30.
And if you look on
this thing here,
you can see there's a line
that corresponds to 10,
there's a line that
corresponds to 100.
We're going to be
right around in there.
So the relative density is
going to be right around 0.01.
So you can use the diagram
to get the thickness
and to get the density.
OK, are we good?
We're good?
So I've written some notes,
and I'll just scan those
and I'll put them
in the Stellar site.
So here's another example
here-- and in this example,
it's set up a little
bit differently.
So in this example here,
we're not told the material,
but we're told the
thickness of the foam.
So this time we want
to get the material,
and we want to get the
density of the foam.
So here we've got
the specification.
We're told the mass is
2 and 1/2 kilograms.
The area of contact is
0.025 meters squared.
We're told the thickness-- here
thickness is 20 millimeters.
We've got a drop height
of 1 meter again.
And the velocity
of impact is then
going to be 4.5 meters
per second again.
And since we know T, we know
that the strain rate is going
to be around 225 per second.
We can calculate the energy
absorbed-- [? MGH-- ?]
25 joules.
We can calculate the energy
absorbed per unit volume,
because we've got the
area and the thickness--
so I'm just going to divide that
by the area and the thickness.
Now we have 5 times 10 to the
4th joules per cubic meter.
And we're told that we're
supposed to design it
so the package can withstand
a deceleration of 100g--
and so that gives
you a maximum force.
And here we've got a maximum
allowable peak stress of 10
of the 5 Newtons
per meter squared.
So here we have our curve for
the elastomeric foams again--
let's assume it's going
to be an elastomeric foam,
but we don't know
what kind of foam.
So the way you
solve this problem
is that you make a
guess for what Es is.
So remember, these diagrams
are all normalized by Es.
So to plot a point on there,
we need to know what Es is.
So here, we're going
to make a guess,
and we're going to assume that
Es is 100 megapascals to start.
And if we had that value
of Es, we know W, up here,
and we know sigma p there.
So we just divide those
values of W and sigma p by Es,
and we get these
two values here.
And we plot those two
values on the thing here.
So here's our point A--
and that corresponds
to that first guess
of 100 mega Pascals
for the modulus of the solid.
So that's not necessarily
the final answer,
that's not the right answer--
that's just somewhere to start.
So the thing to notice is,
if we have that point there,
the strain rate there is
probably not quite right.
This upper bound
here is-- let's see.
Got to get closer.
Oh, let's see-- that's 10 to
the minus 2, that's 10 to the 2.
So the strain rate we want
to be is closer up to here,
it's not quite down there.
So we're not at the
right strain rate.
But the thing to notice is that
if we draw a line of slope 1--
so there's this dash
line of slope 1--
when we move up and down that
line, we're just changing Es.
Because everything is
normalized with respect
to Es-- if that line
has a slope of 1,
then we're just moving up
and down with respect to Es.
So what we do is we
scoot up the line
to get to the point that's
on the right strain rate.
So if this was a strain
rate of 100, or around 200,
we want to be at point
B. And then from point B,
we can read off what's
the value of W over Es,
and sigma p over Es.
And from that, we can back out
what the solid modulus we want
is.
So these are the values
that we read off the chart.
This gives us an Es
of 28 mega Pascals.
And again, you can go to this
more detailed diagram here,
and if you read off the sigma
p over Es, and the W over Es,
the density you
want is about 0.1.
So it tells you the
modulus of the solid,
and from that you
can pick a solid,
and it tells you the density.
Are we good?
OK, so I have one more.
So there's a slightly different
way you can do it, too.
So now I want to talk about
bicycle helmets-- you're
my bicycle helmet person.
So this is another
little case study
that involves a slightly
different way to do this.
And this involves a
slightly different diagram.
So the idea here is to choose a
material for a bicycle helmet.
And as you probably all
know, the bicycle helmets
have a hard shell, and they
have some sort of foamy liner.
And the foam's usually
around 20 millimeters thick.
And you want something
that's light,
because you don't want your
helmet to be too heavy--
but you want something
that will absorb
the energy from the impact.
So I've set this up here-- so
we assume the mass of the head
is about 3 kilograms.
And we assume that
it can withstand
a deceleration of
something like 300g--
and so then you can get a force
mass times the acceleration,
because you have the force.
And I've assumed an area
of contact of something
like 0.01 meters squared, so
that gives you a peak stress.
So this method here
is based on the idea
that you have these material
selection charts for foams.
Remember we talked
about that earlier.
And this is the compressive
stress at 25% strain.
So the idea is
that axis there is
meant to represent
the plateau stress,
and this axis here represents
the densification strain.
And these dashed
lines here correspond
to basically a value
of W-- and energy
absorbed per unit volume.
So this is an energy
absorbed per unit volume
of 0.001 megajoules per
cubic meter, 0.01, and so on.
So if you know the peak
stress that you can tolerate,
for the numbers I
gave you it works out
to be 0.9 mega Pascals-- so here
it's just a little less than 1.
So that's the peak stress
that you can tolerate there.
And you can see that
the material that's
going to absorb the most
energy-- so you're absorbing
more energy as you move
over this way on the curve
on the plot-- so the material
that's going to do the best
is something like an expanded
polystyrene that's 5% dense.
So I've highlighted
that in red-- expanded
polystyrene that's 5% dense.
And then this is the
densification strain here.
And you know that the lines
of the energy absorption
are just the stress
times the strain.
So you can basically
just read off from here
that expanded polystyrene
that was 5% dense
would be a good choice
for a bicycle helmet foam.
Would you like to add anything
about bicycle helmet foams?
I think that is exactly
what they use, yes.
So this is just another way
to do this kind of thing.
And I did one more
little calculation here--
if you know the thickness of the
foam is, say, 20 millimeters,
and we've estimated the
area of the contact,
you can figure out what
the energy absorbed is
per unit volume, and from
that you can back out
the energy in terms of joules,
and from that you can back out
the velocity that's the
maximum speed that one
would want to get dinged
at on your bicycle.
And the maximum speed works
out about 22 miles an hour.
So that's just another example.
Are we good?
OK-- yeah, exactly,
your head would
be hitting the ground
at 22 miles an hour
which, would be ouchy.
Which is why you want
to wear your helmet,
because your skull will not
be happy if that happens.
And your brain
will not be happy.
And you will not be happy.
And your mom and dad will be
really, really, really unhappy.
So you don't want
that to happen.
so I have a few
minutes left-- and I
know I've done this
for the people in 3032,
but I was going to buy
woodpecker talk, because it's
about energy absorption.
So if you don't want to watch
it, if you've already seen it,
you can go.
But there are some people--
you guys haven't seen it,
and you haven't seen it.
There's a few people
that haven't seen.
And it's cute, involves birds.
And it involves
energy absorption--
so I thought I would do
this woodpecker talk.
So Barry, this is
all just slides.
I don't know if you want to
do the lights differently.
I'm not going to write
anything on the board,
I'm just going to talk.
BARRY: Well, if it will help
them see the slides better then
certainly.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah,
I think maybe we
could turn the lights
down a little, please.
BARRY: Let's try this one.
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, there we go.
That's good.
Yeah, now I don't feel like
I'm looking in the spotlight
so much.
That's good.
OK, so you guys know that
I like to watch birds.
And you know that
I work on foams.
And if you look at bird books,
sometimes the bird books
say that woodpeckers
can withstand the impact
from pecking because they
have a special material
between their skulls
and their brains.
And I thought, oh,
well I study foams,
and I'm interested in
woodpeckers-- I should find out
what this special material is.
So I started looking into this.
And it turns out there
is no special material.
People have looked at the
anatomy of woodpecker brains
and skulls, and there
is no special material.
But it turns out there were
also a group of neurologists
in the late 1970s who got
interested in why woodpeckers
don't get brain injury, and
they took high speed video
of a woodpecker pecking.
And it was kind of amazing
what they found out.
So it turns out the
woodpeckers can withstand
incredibly high decelerations--
much higher than our brains
could withstand.
And so I kind of got
interested in this,
and I decided to try to
figure out how it works.
So here's an acorn woodpecker.
And let's see-- I got
a little video here.
Wait a minute-- there we go.
There we go.
So here's a little
acorn woodpecker.
These live in California.
Anybody from California?
Yeah-- have you seen them?
No, OK.
Well you have not been
looking carefully.
So here's our little acorn--
and you can see they peck-- oh?
Like around San Francisco.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHS]
LORNA GIBSON: So
they're pecking,
and when they're pecking--
they don't just go bonk.
They do this repeatedly-- they
can peck at 10 or 20 times
per second.
So the question is, why
don't they get brain injury?
So, first of all,
why do they peck?
So as we in that little
video, that woodpecker
was foraging-- it was trying
to get little things out
of the bark.
And woodpeckers eat insects,
and so the bird books
say that they can actually
hear insects scurrying around
under the bark, and
they'll peck at the bark
and forage to try
to get insects.
And there's one other anatomical
feature of woodpeckers,
which is kind of amazing-- and
you can see it in this picture
here.
So this is the
woodpecker tongue,
and the tongue is
connected to something
called the hyoid process.
And the hyoid process wraps
around their eyeballs.
And then when they
peck-- I mean,
the idea is they're
making a hole in the tree,
and they've got to get
their tongue into the hole
to get the bug.
And the end of their tongue
has little barbs on it.
And when they contract
this thing here,
their tongue scoots out
and gets the little bugs.
So they pick partly to
forage, but they also
build something
called cavity nests.
So they'll find a tree
that's started to rot,
and they'll drill a
sort of horizontal hole,
and then they'll drill
a cup underneath that,
and they lay the eggs
and have their nest
at the bottom of the cup.
And then they also-- especially
at this time of year, in fact,
today I heard
woodpeckers drumming--
so it's one of these mating
things, one of these courtship
things.
So woodpeckers will peck on a
hollow branch or a hollow tree,
just to make a big
loud noise to say,
here I am, looking for sex, I'm
ready, this is my territory.
And so in the spring--
so this time of year
you hear woodpeckers drumming.
And I think naturally they
do this on hollow trees
to try to make a
big sound, but they
have adapted to metal
downspouts, which
are also very effective
for making this loud noise.
And people who've-- I
wrote a paper on this--
people who have read my paper
sometimes email me and say, oh,
I heard you know about
woodpecker pecking.
How can I get them to stop
drumming on my downspout?
Because it's kind of
annoying, if you're
the human inside the house.
So anyway, they peck
for these reasons.
And then acorn woodpeckers are
special-- acorn woodpeckers
are what I think of as
the champions of pecking.
And they do one
more behavior-- so
here's from David Sibley's
beautiful Guide to Birds,
here's the acorn woodpecker.
They store acorns in
what's called a granary,
and they look at old tree trunks
that are beginning to rot,
and they pick holes
in the tree trunk
and they store the
acorns in the holes.
So see all those little
dark dots on that trunk?
Those are all holes that the
acorn woodpecker has pecked.
And they'll do this-- they
live in social groups,
so there might be like 10 or
20 of them living together,
and they'll peck like 10,000
holes into their granary.
There will be thousands and
thousands of these holes.
And here we have
the acorn woodpecker
with the acorn in its beak, and
you can see some of these holes
have acorns, and some
of them are empty.
So here is the acorn
woodpecker in action.
And here's the little video
again-- I won't play the video.
So I often give this
talk for non-engineers,
so I'm going to explain
some things-- there's
going to be some
writing on the slides
that you guys already know.
So the impact force depends
on the deceleration--
how quickly the brain stops
when the beak hits the tree.
And I should mention, these
videos are from the Cornell
Lab of Ornithology-- they have
an amazing collection of bird
audio, like bird calls, bird
songs, and bird photographs
and videos.
It's incredible, the
collection that they've got.
And then I explain
what acceleration
is-- so I'm going
to put acceleration
in terms of gravity.
And when the beak
hits the tree, there's
going to be a
deceleration on impact.
And just as a comparison,
human brain injury
occurs roughly at about 100g.
And so the question is,
how much deceleration
can the woodpecker brain take?
And that's where the
neurologists in the Bay Area
come into the picture.
They found out that
there was a park
ranger-- I think maybe at
Point Reyes, just north
of San Francisco.
And he had an acorn
woodpecker that, I don't, had
an injured wing or something.
Anyway, he had this acorn
woodpecker that he kept.
And they were able to use
this acorn woodpecker,
and they took high-speed video
of the woodpecker pecking.
So from the high-speed video,
the video that they took
went at something like
2,000 frames a second.
So they have a picture of
where the head is every 2,000th
of a second.
So if you know the
position at these times,
you can get the velocity, and
you can get the deceleration.
So they measured
the deceleration,
and they measured
some amazing things.
So they measured that on
impact, the woodpecker's bill
was going something
like 15 miles an hour.
And the decelerations
were up to 1,500g--
so many times more than
what we can withstand.
And they also measured
the stopping time--
and they thought it was between
about 1/500th to 1/1,000th
of a second.
And that's going to
be important later on.
So one of the interesting
things about this
was how they got this
whole thing set up.
So I don't know how many of
you do UROPs-- but you know,
part of the thing in doing
UROPs, and doing experiments
in the lab is just how do
you do the experiments?
So you know, the park rangers
got the acorn woodpecker,
that's all very good.
But they have to
get the woodpecker
to peck in front of
a camera, and they
have to get the
camera to turn on
as it's pecking-- so there's
some experimental challenges.
So the important thing,
the critical thing,
is the date of the paper.
This was written in 1979,
which meant they probably
did the experiments in 1978.
And I was a graduate
student in 1978.
And I can report there were
no Apple computers in 1978--
there were no laptops.
You couldn't just kind of do
your little PowerPoint slides.
And most offices had something
called an IBM Selectric
typewriter-- I don't know if
you've ever seen the old IBM
typewriters.
But the typewriters, when
you typed on the typewriters,
they made these noises,
and it sounded kind of
like a woodpecker pecking.
And the ranger had one of these
typewriters in his office,
and he had discovered that if
he typed on the typewriter,
the woodpecker thought, oh,
there's another woodpecker.
I'll start pecking.
And so they used the
typewriter as a way
to get the woodpeckers to peck.
And I think they
had some old stump,
and I don't know if they
put nuts or peanut butter
or something into the
stump to get the woodpecker
to peck at it--
because they needed
to peck at a particular spot,
so they have the camera all
set up.
So anyway, they had
this whole arrangement
to do this high-speed video
of the woodpecker pecking.
OK, so it goes
that up to 1,500g,
which is kind of amazing.
And then, remember also,
they do this repeatedly--
they do it at like 10
or 20 times a second.
Then this is just
explaining what
stress is-- but you already
know what stress is,
so I'm going to skip over that.
And so the way you
can think about this
is to think about it in
terms of a scaling argument.
So imagine there's the
brain and there's the skull,
and when the head hits the
tree, the brain's going
to accelerate, and the
brain and the skull
are both going to decelerate.
And you can think of the stress
as the force over the area.
So the force is the mass times
the deceleration over the area.
So that value for the
woodpecker, you can say,
is roughly equal to the same
values, but for the human.
So what that argument
relies on is the idea
that the stress to cause
damage in the woodpecker brain
is similar to the
stress to cause damage
in the human brain.
And that's not
totally unreasonable.
So if you look at
bone, for example,
like when you measure the
strength of the whale bones,
it's not going to be that
different from what you
would measure from human bones.
So when you look at a
particular type of tissue,
and you look at the strength
of it in different species,
the properties aren't that
different from one species
to another.
So let's say the
brain tissue gets
damaged at the same
stress in the two species.
So we can write this
sort of equation down.
And the mass is going to depend
on the density of the brain
tissue times the
volume-- and the volume
goes as the radius cubed.
And the density is going to be
the same for the woodpecker,
or for the human-- so
assume the brain tissue has
the same kind of basic stuff.
So the mass goes as the radius
cubed, and the area of contact
is going to go as
the radius squared.
And so there's a radius term.
So you can say the radius
times the deceleration
in the woodpecker should
be equal to the radius
times the deceleration
of the human.
And obviously, the
woodpecker radius
is going to be a lot smaller,
so the woodpecker deceleration
is going to be a lot bigger.
So part of the thing is the
brain is just a lot smaller.
Then there's another
factor that comes into it--
these are photographs
of an acorn woodpecker
skull and a human
skull that I got
from the Museum of Comparative
Zoology at Harvard.
So this is looking
down on the top,
and this is an elevation view.
And if you think of the brain as
roughly a hemisphere-- I mean,
obviously it's not a
perfect hemisphere,
but let's say it's
roughly a hemisphere--
the orientation of
the brain in the skull
is slightly different in
the birds and in the human.
So if you think of it
as being this way on,
and in the woodpecker it's
turned roughly this way on,
and the contact area-- think
of this as the contact area.
The projected area would be a
full circle, and in the human,
the brain is more this way on.
And then the projected
contact area is a semicircle.
So there's a factor
of 2 difference,
just because of the
orientation of the brain.
And so I've put the factor
of 2 that accounts for that.
So then I could say
the deceleration
that the woodpecker
can take is twice
the ratio of the radii of the
human and the woodpecker brain,
times the deceleration
the human can take.
And this was around
100g, remember.
So then I wanted to know
what the ratio of the sizes
was, and I thought,
oh geez-- I'm
going to have to mess
around with skulls,
and try to make some
sort of measurements,
and this is going to be a drag.
And then I found this paper--
I couldn't believe it--
I found this paper called
"Brain Size in Birds."
And this guy had
table after table
after table of the mass of
the brain in different birds--
and he had the acorn
woodpecker, lucky for me.
So if you just assume that the
brain is roughly a hemisphere,
if you have the mass,
you can work out roughly
what the radius is.
So it turns out
there's a factor of 8
difference between the radii.
And so the human brain is
about eight times the size
of the woodpecker.
And then if you take into
account this factor of 2,
that means the
woodpecker should be
able to tolerate a deceleration
of 16 times what the human can.
So remember, I
said the human can
take about 100-- so this would
get the woodpecker up to 1,600.
But they measured 1,500.
And I'm a civil
engineer, originally,
I like big factors of
safety-- that's a little too
close for comfort for me.
And so it turns out there's
one more factor that matters.
People have studied human brain
injury pretty extensively,
and one of the things
they've looked at
is how much acceleration you
can tolerate without injury,
relative to the
duration of the impact.
So this is from a car crash
conference-- so here's
the tolerable
acceleration, and here's
the duration of the impact.
And typically, for
human head impacts,
the deceleration occurs
over a few milliseconds--
like over 3 to 10 milliseconds.
So if this is the duration
of the typical head
impact for a human, here's
the range of the tolerable
accelerations between about
80g and 160g-- so you know,
I said around 100.
So we can take this curve, and
now we have this factor of 16,
and we can just scale it
up by our factor of 16
for the woodpecker.
So if I scale it up by the
factor of 16, we're there.
But the duration of the
impacts was more around 1/2
a millisecond, to a
millisecond, so I've
extrapolated this a little bit.
And the duration of
them is up in here.
So this is saying
the woodpecker can
take these sorts of
decelerations here,
and that adds on
another factor of 4.
And these were the
measured decelerations--
1,500 was about the
biggest, and I think it
went to about a few hundred g.
So there's really
three factors--
one is the small
brain size, so there's
this sort of scaling factor.
One is the orientation
of the brain,
that was another factor of 2.
And then there's this
duration of impact,
which is a factor of 4.
And so that's how you can
get this huge decelerations
that they've measured
in the woodpecker when
they're pecking.
So now I have just a
couple more slides.
So woodpeckers have various
adaptations to pecking, too.
So one of the things is they
have amazingly stiff tail
feathers-- you see
the tails here?
You can't quite see it because
this didn't reproduce quite
properly, but the woodpecker
is perched on a tree here,
and the tail is pressed
up against the tree.
And if you think about
pecking, like imagine
if its tail was not pressed
up against the tree--
it would be kind of
grabbing on with its feet,
and it would be trying to peck,
and it would be hard to push.
You know, you need
something to push against.
And so it's got these stiff tail
feathers, which make it easier
to push against the tree.
And so here's the stiff
tail feathers here.
It's also got kind
of unusual feet
for birds-- it's got two toes
forward and two toes back.
And again, if it's
grabbing with its feet,
that helps it get some
purchase to push against.
That's called zygodactyl
in the bird world.
So it's got these
adaptations, the pecking.
And then finally, I
just like this slide
here from The New
Yorker, because it's
a woodpecker pecking
out a woodpecker,
so it seemed kind of cute.
And several people helped
me with this project.
Trey Crisco studies
head injury at Brown.
He actually does work for the
NFL on football brain injuries,
and looks at football helmets.
Sharon Swartz is a
friend of mine at Brown,
who's a biologist.
She studies bat flight.
And she just thought this
was kind of a cool project.
So, in fact, I was walking the
dog last week, a few days ago,
and I saw bats flying
around overhead at night.
And it was so great to
see the little bats.
So I had to immediately
email Sharon,
and say, bats-- there's
bats in my neighborhood.
Andy Biewener runs the
Concord Field Station,
and studies animal locomotion,
and I talked to him about it.
Jeremy Trimble was the one who
gave me the skull pictures,
and Matt Dawson was
a student helped
me do some of the images.
So that's my woodpecker talk.
So that's the end of
energy absorption,
I just thought that
was kind of amusing.
So next time, we'll start
talking about sandwich panels.
So, let's see--
Monday's a holiday.
I will be in Toronto on
Monday, seeing my family.
In fact, I'm going to see
one of my old professors--
I'm going to my old fluid
mechanics professor on Monday
and have lunch.
I'll see my family
on the weekend.
And so we'll meet
Wednesday next week,
and I'll start the bit
on sandwich panels.
So I think there's two lectures
on engineering sandwich panels,
and then there's a lecture
on natural sandwich panels--
so bird skulls, for example,
are natural sandwich panels.
So I'll talk about that.
And then I think
the last lecture--
there's only a handful of
lectures left-- the last one I
think I talk about natural
materials, because you know,
I like that.
So I just do that for fun.